The Joe Rogan Experience did Lily pep
die in the ring or something that name
stands out to me for some reason I don't
believe so okay Benny Perrette died in
the ring Benny Perrette was killed by
Emile Griffith uh Emil Griffith beat him
to death in the ring after Benny
Perrette uh teased him for being gay he
kept uh talking [ __ ] about him being gay
and he beat the [ __ ] out of him he beat
him oh was he gay I believe so I believe
so I think that was the rumor
wow he beat him to death but that that
wasn't illegal right nope I mean he
wasn't trying to he's trying to knock
him out but it's a I forget what they
call that fight see if you can find that
fight because that's a rough one to
watch the end Emile Griffin was that the
fight that like chained boxing but they
had to like like crack down on like
safety rules no no the one that did that
was uh uh Ray Boom Boom Mancini versus
duck Kim
that was the one where um duck who Kim
died and uh I think that was when they
started to go to 12 rounds I think they
go went to 12 rounds slightly after that
because they were they were doing 15
rounds before and I think uh duck who
Kim died in the 13th or 14th round I
forget which round I think they decided
that 12 rounds would be the right one so
this is Emil Griffith versus
Benny Perrette and this is the one where
uh you know he was taunting him and Emil
Griffith just [ __ ] people I'm
guessing the guy on the right was the
gay guy
the guy on the right is Emil Griffith
yes okay that's that's the gay guy with
the I I don't know if he's gay but
that's what that's what he was being
pleased about yeah and that was he was
definitely being teased about that but
that was the rumor that he was but look
dude he just beats the [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
look at this so he's stuck in the ropes
and Emil Griff is just teeing off on him
while he's out so he's trapped in the
ropes and he collapses and then he's
dead he's dead right now yeah he's dead
man wow wow they beat him to death
watch that again Watch that combination
again because it's so crazy uppercut and
then he he backs up right hand yeah
right this right here right here should
have stopped it right right hand right
hand this is crazy right hand right in
yeah he's trapped the only thing keeping
him up is the punches the punches are so
hard they're they're keeping his body
upright as he's leaning up against the
Rope because he dead right here bang
well he's out right here right like
right there you could have stopped it
right there right there for sure right
here turning away and he's hitting it
with bomb after bomb and he keeps going
one two one two one two one two I mean
he's just swinging at him afterwards and
the refs just sit there like this yeah
there's been some horrific moments like
that dude remember that who was the one
guy I can't remember his [ __ ] name
but he Ray Mercer versus Tommy Morrison
wait a minute that's that's from Rocky
right yeah no no I never saw that one
that might be the worst one ever I'm
talking about the guy who he he didn't
die in the ring but but he had like all
this promise oh Gerald McClellan maybe
maybe that's what I'm saying 100 of you
talking about yeah he was the guy that
was a rival for Roy Jones Jr so as Roy
Jones Jr was a champion he was a champ
and he fought Nigel Ben and he almost
put Nigel Ben out in the first round but
they collided heads at one point in the
fight and Nigel Ben uh hit him with some
real good punches and he went down took
a knee and then he went back to his
corner and he he quit and they couldn't
believe that he like he took a 10 count
and everyone's like I can't believe he's
taking a 10 count and he went back to
his corner and he was so [ __ ] up
yeah this is him so he had Nigel been in
all sorts of trouble knocked him out of
the ring right Nigel Ben was one of the
toughest [ __ ] to ever box he
got back in the ring and survived so
Nigel Ben knocked out of the ring and
here's him after that so Jerry McClellan
is just emptying the [ __ ] gas tank
here just swinging with everything he
had and Gerald McClellan was all [ __ ]
murderous puncher he knocked everybody
out so he was assuming he was about to
knock Nigel Ben out too but Nigel Ben
wasn't going anywhere and so Gerald
McClellan got [ __ ] drained and then
Nigel started catching him look at that
left hook Nigel catches him and Gerald
tags him again right hand uppercut but
Nigel van just kept coming and look he
catches him with that right hand look at
that left hook imagine being that hurt
in the first round and Nigel Ben just
comes storming out later in the fight
yeah that's it's crazy the resilience
crazy the endurance so Gerald McClellan
emptied this gas tank and Nigel's
catching him now he catches him with a
big left hook
and at one point in time they collided
heads and it was a bad one it was like a
bang
you think that's what did it no no no it
was all these punches for sure but it
was like I think it was a collision of
heads as well that that someone had
identified that was really bad but he
hit him with some [ __ ] bombs
and look he dropped him again so Gerald
eventually comes back and drops Nigel
again the eighth round and Nigel gets
back up and he's like still not going
anywhere boom hits him with the left
hook this is after getting dropped again
imagine hitting the [ __ ] with
everything you got look at this
combination boom Nigel over the top of
that right hand
so that what the point is this was a
[ __ ] war and there's another
brilliant one so we see like where he
takes a knee
boom look at that right hand this is
[ __ ] another right hand so that's
where it was that's where he takes a
knee yeah this is sad so he decided to
stay down
so he gets hit he gets I guess he got up
for the first one right is that what
they're saying
oh so he goes down a second time
so this is the second time and then look
you see him like wincing in pain like
holding his head and that's when he
decided to stay down
and so everybody's like I can't believe
he you know he quit on his knee like
that but then he went back into his
corner and he slumped and uh he really
never recovered he went to the hospital
and he's alive still but he's like
severely disabled and I believe he's
blind what did it cause like a brain
bleed yeah yeah yeah I mean that's the
risk that these guys have taken man I
mean that's a crazy sport you're you're
throwing Haymakers at each other with
like thick padding over the top of it
and that's that's him today
and this like greatly affected Roy Jones
Jr too because you got to think that Roy
and him almost fought right like they
that was like a big super fight that
people were setting up for the future
and Roy and him down the line did wind
up fighting that could have been Roy or
that it could have been Gerald like it
could have been neither one of them yeah
like when when two guys are that good
and they're swinging the way those guys
were at each other my money would have
still been on Roy though
Roy and his pride was [ __ ] stupid
good he was ridiculous and this Prime no
one can touch him he he would win entire
rounds without him being hit to me you
know what I'll compare Roy to is
Anderson Silva
similar in that way like they were just
so dominant for a while and he would win
in such stylish fashion you know where
it was it wasn't just that he was
winning but he just made you look silly
you know he was doing movie [ __ ] he was
doing movie [ __ ] Roy put his hand behind
his back and then knocked out with one
punch yeah put his hand behind his back
ducked and then popped him with a right
hand and knocked him out but just like
both his like eventually it catches up
to you where it's like you know it's
like you hit an age where like you don't
realize but you just a millisecond
slower yeah there's that there's also
this other speculation that speculation
is that he went up to heavyweight to
fight John Ruiz and so he had to pack on
weight and then he went back down to
light heavyweight and I think the losing
the weight to get back down diminished
him severely and then he fought Antonio
Tarver and Antonio Tarboro was a
murderous puncher and a [ __ ] of
a boxer Antonio Tarver could box and he
said in the ring to Roy because they had
had one fight previously where it went
to a decision and uh you know and Roy
had some excuses I guess and so he says
in the ring for the second fight he got
excuses tonight Roy
the referee goes any questions any
questions and he goes got any excuses
tonight Roy and Roy didn't say anything
and Tarver wind up knocking him out and
then after that he just kept getting
knocked out right he got knocked out bad
after that what do you think that is
when after somebody gets knocked out
it's almost like it's easier to knock
him out after today well he fought Glenn
Johnson after that who is a very
talented uh Contender who people like I
think Glenn Johnson was a little older
at the time and maybe people overlooked
him he like he really had great success
like later in his career but Glenn
Johnson knocked out Roy in a scary
knockout pull that one up Glenn Johnson
Roy Jones Jr that was a scary one
because this was after the Tarver one
but the Tarver one he was kind of he was
conscious but he was [ __ ] up I mean
Tarver cracked him and he went down but
he was out right but he was moving
around this one's even scarier because
he bangs the back of his head when he
goes down
and this was the comeback fight right
and so Glenn Johnson was like a suitable
comeback opponent but nobody told Glenn
Johnson that like Glenn Johnson came to
that fight to win and Glenn Johnson has
his high guard he's like really
difficult style to deal with and super
super tough guy
just very very skillful and you know
this was Roy coming off of getting ko'd
and whenever a guy comes off of getting
ko'd the odds of him getting KO to again
go up I don't know it depends on the
person some of it doesn't go up at all
some of them it only goes up slightly
but some of them it goes up a lot for
whatever reason it might be the damage
they took from the first knockout it
could be a lot of factors look at this
boom he hits him in that right hand look
how he goes out
he goes out stiff he banged his head off
the ground like watch that again because
it is a [ __ ] brutal series of punches
he hits him with
back here goes so he gets him up against
the ropes sets him up for the right hand
and boom he's out one hard right hand to
the side of the head and Roy's out
that was a rough one but that's nothing
Mercer versus Tommy Morris I think it's
like your brain going we're not taking
any chances probably because there's
probably some something to that but get
ray Mercer versus Tommy Morrison this
one was one of the worst and this one
was one after the movie so Ray Mercer
people thought about him as like this
like gold medalist in the Olympics
murderous puncher like he was a guy
who's on the up like he was coming up
and somehow or another they set him up
with Tommy Morrison who was a very good
boxer and had beaten some good guys but
he was just coming off of this movie so
he was the [ __ ] the in the Rocky
movies and he's fighting a guy that's
just been doing nothing but boxing now
Tommy Morrison's a movie star now and
he's a young guy he's got to be
distracted I mean he's got to be more
focused right and he's fighting a guy
that he probably would have lost to
anyway because Ray Mercer was a
[ __ ] and so Tommy is doing well
in the fight for a while but then Mercer
eventually catches him because Tommy
starts getting tired and this one of the
things about Tommy Morrison if you look
at Tommy Morrison in the early stages of
his fights he was always better he would
fade
and eventually Ray Mercer catches him
and he hits him with that right hand and
watch this boom he's in trouble here
right boom boom boom boom now this is
why it's the worst one ever oh bro he's
Tangled Up in the ropes and the referee
is too small to pull Mercer off of him
so he hits him with multiple punches
wise how cold look at this this is over
now referee doesn't get in there look
look how he gets in there the referees
just say hey you stop hey you he's
scared because he's a little old guy he
shouldn't be referee in this fight these
are two Elite heavyweights these are
enormous men and this poor referee is
old got a little pot belly he doesn't
want to dive in there and get [ __ ]
murked yeah yeah and so because of that
Tommy Morrison takes Haymakers look he's
out cold and Ray Mercer is just full
blast teeing off and another left hook
after that while the referee was holding
onto his arms
bro
that might be the worst did he survive
he lived but he was never the same boxer
again no no way he he beat some good
guys after that he actually beat George
Foreman after that
yeah old George Foreman old George
Foreman he won a decision off of uh old
George Foreman look at that left hook
boom boom boom right hand I mean this is
horrendous dude this is we're looking at
it from a different angle now look at
this I mean come on man boom and then
still
he's fully out cold that he got hit four
or five times clean this is like Benny
perret all over again this easily could
have been the end of his life yeah it
usually could have been and probably
changed his brain because right here
like I mean what is this rough weight
doing I mean but seriously dude like
this probably probably changed his brain
forever yeah I mean what I mean it's
crazy what is it this reference waiting
to see I don't know man that is a crazy
beat because when you see a [ __ ]
get hit in the face and they're not
trying to stop it I think the fight's
over you need a big referee with big men
you just you need someone who can
separate those you need Herb Dean he'd
be diving in like he diving from first
base mark Goddard Mark goddard's a big
guy you need to jump Big John McCarthy
was always great at it he's a big guy
you want a big guy for big guys